pour en parler nous sommes avec que
tigran viega vian journalistes pour la
revue géopolitique conflit tigran les
gavant merci d'être en direct avec nous
sur rt france alors on le disait à la
trêve entre l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan
apparaît très fragile mais de quel trêve
par le ton aujourd'hui au juste c'est
plutôt une trêve humanitaire c'est
plutôt un apaisement des tensions
comment ça se passe sur le terrain
heureusement temps déterminé du karabagh
vit toujours sous les bombardements
systématiques de la coalition turco
azéri alors ce qu'on peut comprendre
aussi c'est que les turco azéri n'ont
pas forcément intérêt à ce cessez-le-feu
car sur le terrain et non pas énormément
progressé alors qu'il y avait un
objectif militaire quand même de
conquêtes territoriales
certes il domine pas le territoire mais
domine l'espace aérien et on peut voir
aussi à certains déséquilibres en termes
de rapport de force
étant donné que l'arménie le karabagh ne
sont pas approvisionnés en armement
régulier comme c'est le cas de
l'azerbaïdjan qui reçoit c'est de façon
continue d'énormes quantités de drones
kamikaze de la turquie et d'israël
alors si vous voyez aujourd'hui les
affrontements excessivement violents ont
lieu sur le front sud
le franc suisse est un petit peu le
point faible du karabagh c'est une sans
relief qui est plutôt plat et c'est une
zone assez stratégique un retour du
petit bourg de radio tu alors on peut
comprendre que la coalition turco azéri
avec leurs mercenaires jihadistes et
aussi des éléments de l'armée
pakistanaise essaie à tout prix de
percer ce front pour faire une jonction
avec la république autonome de
nakhitchevan donc appartient à
l'azerbaïdjan et qui se situe entre
l'arménie et la turquie est donc
l'objectif final de cette opération
serait très probablement de faire une
jonction avec ce territoire et donc
d'étouffer complètement la maison c'est
le scénario le pire scénario que
appréhende les forces arméniennes et
c'est pour ça que les combats sont
excessivement violent à l'heure où je
vous parle vous parliez de mercenaires
islamistes donc envoyé sur le
le ferons notamment par la turquie
l'azerbaïdjan
lui dément est ce qu'il ya des preuves
de vie de ces mercenaires islamistes
absolument on a tout un travail a été
fait déjà par les meilleurs reporters de
la presse internationale le président
macron a été formel à ce sujet et sa lg
d'une d'un dossier excessivement
dangereux très grave la turquie importe
si vous voulez dans le caucase à nouveau
foyer de tension de chaos
c'est j'attire votre attention sur le
fait que l'azerbaïdjan qui est un pays
souverain
un pays qui a une armée régulière et
qu'un pib dont le 10 de pib de la
défense est équivalent pib de l'arménie
dont qui n'a a priori pas besoin
si vous voulez de combattants étrangers
importe des mercenaires dans le but si
vous voulez de déstabiliser aussi la
russie et l'iran qui sont excessivement
inquiets de cette de ce qui peut être
une ligne rouge en tout cas qui vient
d'être franchi cerdan cet accord pour le
moment il reste temporaire
quelles sont les perspectives va déjà là
le côté positif cet accord qu'on peut
qu'on peut prendre en considération
c'est que la turquie est restée en
dehors des négociations de ces derniers
jours la diplomatie turque
le midd affaires étrangères turquie
était à bakou en déplacement font des
pieds et des mains pour changer le
format des négociations qui est un
format trilatérale un jeu le groupe de
minsk coprésidé par la france les états
unis et la russie
donc l'objectif de la turquie c'était de
bouleverser cet équilibre pour pouvoir
négocier en position de force alors ce
qu'on peut constater c'est que les
russes ont tenu bon et continue à être à
la manoeuvre dans les négociations donc
la première chose positive c'est la
turquie et pro est à l'écart mais est-ce
qu'elle va s'arrêter la question c'est
si la turquie n'est pas arrêtée au
karabagh d'autres foyers peuvent être
être allumées par par la politique
erratique du pyromane
le pyromane qui est monsieur erdogan je
pense notamment aux balkans alors vous
le disiez être la prochaine étape si
vous voulez vous lisiez à moscou mène
des négociations
ça durait dix heures samedi
après négociation un règlement pacifique
est il toujours possible et par quoi
doit-il passer peut-il passer je pense
que la mère des priorités à l'heure où
je vous parle c'est la protection des
civils quels qu'ils soient que soient
les civils azerbaïdjanais civils
arméniens et ça passe aussi par là la
reconnaissance de la république
autoproclamée du haut karabagh qui est
un état de fait depuis 29 ans et 29 ans
le haut karabagh et consulté en état
certes non reconnue mais s'est dotée de
tous les attributs de cet état est donc
une solution serait au nom de la
responsabilité de protéger de
reconnaître l'indépendance du karabagh
pour qu'ils puissent prendre part
activement un aigle à là on a honte
termine donc on a un petit problème de
liaison en tout cas merci à vous tigran
league avant je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste pour la revue géopolitique
conflit